mg emotionalisiert heute ein thema das
eigentlich in vergessenheit geraten ist
über die vergangenen drei vier jahren
muss man sagen es geht um das thema
flüchtlinge es geht um das thema
migration heute bei bild live zu gast
war nämlich der scheidende
bundesinnenminister aus seehofer und der
hat erzählt dass mittlerweile mehr als
1000 flüchtlinge pro tag wieder nach
deutschland kommt wenn man das
hochrechnet und das hat er getan dann
sind es bis zu 30.000 pro monat aufs
jahr gerechnet werden dass dann
360.000 also eine wirklich mittelgroße
stadt das thema ist viel zu ernst als
dass man es regieren könnte wir haben es
und das ist das perverse an der sache
mit einer übrigen kriegsführung zu tun
wir sehen beispielsweise dass der
belarussische präsident ganz bewusst
flüchtlinge migranten an die grenze der
eu an die ostgrenze also nach polen card
fliegen lässt und um dort druck auf die
eu auszuüben das ist eine perversion
nicht zu überbieten da waren auch
unterirdischer ist beispielsweise eine
aussage des grünen vorsitzende tarek der
minister der nächsten regierung werden
will und er sagt man sollte doch einfach
diese flüchtlinge in europa verteilen
also quasi einen despoten wie dem
belarussischen präsidenten noch den arm
zu reich und zu sagen super dass du uns
die flüchtlinge schickst wir verteilen
die dann einfach bei uns nein das darf
nicht sein die grünen müssen aufwachen
müssen dass ihre migrations trauma
heraus aus dieser scheinwelt in der sie
sich befinden müssen die realität
anerkennen was es ebenfalls braucht es
braucht ganz schnell auf europäischer
ebene wieder einen flüchtlings gipfel
bei dem ganz klar wird dass sich europa
das sich gerade auch die osteuropäischen
länder dass auch die deutschen wir uns
diese hybride kriegsführung diese
erpressung nicht bieten lassen und dass
wir beim thema flüchtlinge migration ein
ganz ganz klaren kurs born ein kurs
abschreckung und auch der abgrenzung
da würde ich ihnen recht geben
vielleicht sind wir uns zu oft einer
meinung hier also sollten vielleicht die
menge ist robert habe persönlich
einladen aber natürlich natürlich sehe
ich das genauso sich als ich gehört habe
was ich dazu gesagt habe da standen mir
die haare zu berg ich dachte ist man
denn in den fünf jahren immer noch nicht
schlauer geworden ja also flüchtlinge in
europa zu verteilen das ist ja nun
erkennbar gescheitert und das wird sich
auch nichts dran ändern also nochmal vor
dieselbe bahnen zu laufen und noch mal
und noch mal das spricht nicht für
politische klugheit aus meiner sicht die
migrationspolitik ist die offene flanke
europas oder besser gesagt der eu und
nicht ohne grund wird jetzt allenthalben
sogar in sachsen vom vom sächsischen
ministerpräsidenten persönlich davon
gesprochen wir brauchen grenzen wir
müssen die grenzen schützen wir brauchen
mauern zäune das klingt alles sehr
hässlich aber tatsächlich wie in der
energiepolitik wenn man sich von
ideologie leiten lässt dann hat man am
ende probleme die immer schwerer werden
zu bewältigen wir sehen ja auch dass der
verteilungsmechanismus in europa gar
nicht richtig funktioniert also das
kommt ja noch hinzu sondern es gibt da
ja eine ganz klare
wanderungsbewegung auch richtung
deutschland zurück weil die systeme hier
so sind wie sie sind und weil es
möglicherweise oder offensichtlich hier
auch viel leichter ist an leistung zu
kommen und das leben hier offensichtlich
angenehmer ist als in anderen städten
der union für flüchtlinge so und so
lange dass das eine zuzugs bewegung
speziell nach deutschland gibt ist ja
irgendwas auch was die bienen verteilung
schon an sich angeht nicht mehr in
ordnung aber wir sind bei den punkt
einmal der verteilung und wir sind vor
einigen bei den punkt der frage wie
gehen wir überhaupt um welche signale
senden wir nach außen und zu sagen ja
wir nehmen euch alle auf egal auf
welchem wege und aus welchen gründen er
ein hergekommen seid und reichen
sozusagen einen despoten wie dem lukas
schenk aus weißrussland die hand das ist
so das verheerendste signal was man
eigentlich dass außenpolitisch und auch
migrationspolitische und humanitär
senden kraft was ich jetzt sagen das
sagt der viktor orban liegen zurzeit so
also jetzt kann man zu ordern gewiss
unterschiedlicher meinung sein und den
auch für vieles kritisieren aber ich
halte den in der migrationspolitik für
deutlich realistischer als die deutsche
bundeskanzlerin als robert habeck und
als ganz viele andere deutsche politiker
auch ihm wird populismus vorgeworfen
dabei ist in der frage glaube ich
realist und die waren populisten in der
migrationsfrage sitzen meines erachtens
im deutschen bundestag und kanzleramt
natürlich
wollte ich sowieso was sagen sie dazu
wir haben wir haben heute sehr leicht
gemacht ich habe das vor ort live
mitmacht damals 2015 bei mir in der
heimat mit mit den grenzübertritten und
bei mir im wahlkreis im wartebereich mit
bis zu 5000 plätzen nicht schön das will
ich nicht mehr dort muss die bilder die
man erst auch sieht das familien kinder
in den wäldern sind sind natürlich auch
schwierig und dass wir dann da einfach
sagt stacheldraht mauer und vorgeht auch
nicht jetzt was macht weil man muss sich
wirklich was überlegen
eigentlich müssen wir an diesen
furchtbaren schleuser team ein ende
setzt und zwar frühzeitig wenn ihr das
dann hört aus der großteil dieser
menschen mit dem flugzeug kommt also das
sind nicht die ärmsten von den ärmsten
die wirklich hilfe brauchen sondern die
kommende flieger denen wird irgend etwas
vorgegaukelt dann muss sie vor ort seien
leute erwähnt nach deutschland kommt es
ist nicht unbedingt oder wenn es nach
über polen nach deutschland kommt da
fließt nicht sofort milch honig sondern
ihr habt einen harten stand es ist nicht
sicher dass sie über die grenze kommt
also denen wird in fast mafia art werden
die menschen über belarus holen in die
europäische union geschleust und und
dann das verteilen bleibt bei uns der
großteil wissmann und schlimm furchtbar
und jetzt auch noch vor dem winter also
meines auch das muss man ganz ganz
schnell gegen die schleuser zum vorgehen
ich weiß die patentlösung jetzt auch
nicht aber das magere 4
darüber reden wir auch seit 2005 10
natürlich schleuser to mittelmeer und
schleuser routen die es dann gab auch
über den bikern also auch das thema ist
nicht ganz neu und ich glaube wir haben
es in diesem fall hier gerade was wir
sehen was in belarus passiert ja auch
mit einer neuen qualität zu erhöhen
staatlich organisiert der flüchtlings
verschiffung muss man ja schon sagen um
die eu zu spalten oder quasi in einen
wie soll man sagen übrigen krieg dann
hineinzuziehen
das ist natürlich eine zentrale debatte
des migrations thema wird immer größer
werden man hat das im wahlkampf total
runter gespielt natürlich in den letzten
monaten weil das hätte dann applaus von
der falschen seite gegeben das ist ein
ganz großes ganz wesentliches thema
natürlich auch ein thema das dann auch
wieder die die ärmsten in einer
gesellschaft betrifft die daneben
konfrontiert sie mit diesen zuwanderung
mit der steigenden kriminalität die
politik weiß dass weg ich kann aber das
ganze theater das da die politik darum
herum veranstalter gar nicht verstehen
im grunde ist das gar kein kompliziertes
thema ich meine wir haben doch in
ländern in deutschland in der schweiz in
frauenkleidung haben glas der eu
glasklare migrations gesetzt werden
glasklare flüchtlings begriffe jetzt
muss man einfach nur noch dieser
rechtsordnung einmal durchsetzen und
muss sagen dass nicht jeder der eine
grenze übertritt ein flüchtling ist
viele von denen sind migranten und man
kann unter dem titel asyl nicht die
ganze welt darf nehmen das hast du
gesagt wohin das stimmt natürlich aber
der wille der politiker fehlt die eigene
rechtsordnung durchzusetzen und da
machen es ein paar zum beispiel die
poren machen es die wehren sich gegen
diese migranten die mit äxten und
steinen zum teil dort die grenze
überwinden wollen ein herr orban hat das
gemacht und was hat man die eu gemacht
mit terror bahn und mit den mit polen
die polen dürfen jetzt eine busse
bezahlen jeden tag habe ich eine
milliarde und der rollbahn ist
das ist doch einfach die völlig
verschobene wirklichkeit hier diese
polen während sich heldenhaft und
außengrenze orban hat im grunde
schenkenden ablehnung gesetzt und sich
zum dank dazu erklärt worden das zeigt
in der eu fehlt der wille die
rechtsordnung durchzusetzen ich habe
frau merkel damals sogar noch verteidigt
215 weil ich gesagt habe diese heute
wird die deutschland kritisieren wenn
die deutschen jetzt die grenzen gesicht
getreten in griechenland dann hätten die
franzosen und die engländer james kommen
da wieder die deutschen mit ihren
schäferhunden sie haben es vielleicht zu
lange laufen gelassen aber der will die
klaren gesetze durchzuführen die der
welt wir brauchen keinen gipfel wir
brauchen politiker die einfach diese
gesetze des drachen werden
ich glaube wir brauchen beides also für
wir brauchen politiker die vernünftige
gesetze erlassen und wir brauchen
politiker oder ein rechtsordnung die das
auch durchsetzt kenne also so einfach
ist das so funktioniert demokratie so
funktioniert eigentlich staatlichkeit
dass wir uns darüber überhaupt sozusagen
unterhalten müssen ist ja schon es ist
schon absurd genug und doch vielleicht
mit den schleppern da kann ich ihnen die
erfahrung sagen die wir bei uns haben
dieses problem genau gleich und man hat
die schlepper das ist eine industrie das
ist eine illegale industrie wie kannst
du eine industrie zu stören indem du
ihnen die kunden wegnehmen zu ihnen die
kunden kunden weg indem du haut jeden
der über diese schlepper industrie
10.000 euro bezahlt hat nach deutschland
kommt in denen du wieder zurück bringst
dann ist der kunde enttäuscht und sagt
um himmels willen diese schleppen mir
versprochen dass blau ist nehme ich habe
10.000 euro bezahlt jetzt habe mich aber
die deutsche gehört wieder nach hause
geschickt und dann haben diese schlepper
keine kunden mehr was machen wir die
staaten kooperieren mit dem schleppen
die angels kooperieren mit diesem
schleppern und am schluss war das ist ja
sein es gibt ja interessantes beispiel
beispielsweise aus dänemark gibt
zumindest den versuch aus dänemark zu
sagen alle diejenigen die bei uns asyl
haben wollen die dürfen dieses asyl
nicht bei uns im land schon diese
asylantrag sondern es gibt asylzentren
außerhalb und in drittstaaten und da
beispielsweise gibt es dann die
möglichkeit und da wird ein asylantrag
dann beschieden oder eben nicht